so you've written quite a bit about
how artificial intelligence might change
our world
how do you think if we look forward
again it's impossible to predict the
future but
if we look at trends and from the past
and we tried to predict what's going to
happen in the rest of the 21st century
how do you think ai will change our
world
that's a big question you know i'm
mostly a techno optimist i'm not at the
extreme you know the singularity is near
end of the spectrum but i i do think
that
we're likely in for some significantly
improved living standards
some really important progress even just
the technologies that are already kind
of like in the can that haven't defused
you know when i talked earlier about the
j curve it could take 10 20 30 years
for an existing technology to have the
kind of profound effects
and when i look at whether it's you know
vision systems voice recognition problem
solving systems
even if nothing new got invented we
would have a few decades of
progress so i'm excited about that and i
think that's going to
lead to us being wealthier healthier i
mean
the health care is probably one of the
applications i'm most excited about
um so that's good news i don't think
we're going to have the end of work
anytime
soon there's just too many things that
machines
still can't do when i look around the
world and think of whether it's child
care
or health care clean the environment
interacting with people
scientific work artistic creativity
these are things that for now machines
aren't able to do
nearly as well as humans even just
something as mundane as you know folding
laundry or whatever
and many of these i think are going to
be
years or decades before machines catch
up you know i may be surprised on some
of them but but overall
i think there's plenty of work for
humans to do there's plenty of problems
in society that need the human touch so
we'll have to repurpose
we'll have to as machines are able to do
some tasks
people are going to have to reskill and
move into other areas
and that's probably what's going to be
going on for the next you know 10 20 30
years or more
a kind of big restructuring of society
will get wealthier and people will have
to do new skills
now if you turn the dial further i don't
know 50 or 100 years into the future
then you know maybe all bets are off
then it's possible
that that machines will be able to do
most of what people do you know say
one or two hundred years i think it's
even likely and at that point
then we're more in the sort of abundance
economy then we're in a world where
there's really little for the humans can
do economically
uh better than machines other than be
human
and uh you know that will take a
transition as well
kind of more of a transition of how we
get meaning in life and what our values
are
but but shame on us if we screw that up
i mean that should be like great great
news
yeah and it kind of saddens me that some
people see that as like a big problem
you know i think it would be should be
wonderful if people have all the health
and
material things that they need and can
focus on
loving each other and discussing
philosophy and playing and doing all the
other things that don't require work
you